hello you're watching the press preview
a first look at what is on the front
pages of wednesday's newspapers as they
come in
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with
the broadcaster and journalist rachel
johnson and the commentator at the mail
on sunday dan hodges lovely to see both
of you
as ever though we turn our attention
first of all to the front pages
and johnson and johnson has paused the
roll out of its vaccine
in europe due to u.s regulators
launching a review into six
cases of rare blood clots according to
the ft
the prime minister's warning of the
inevitable rise of covet-19 infections
due to reopening some parts of society
is on the front page of the yorkshire
post the daily telegraph says that
almost a quarter
of registered covert deaths are people
who are not dying from the disease
causing calls for the government to
unlock restrictions
more quickly first in the queue that's
the headline
for the sun referring to the huge number
of people in england
who have flocked to the pub for the
first time in months
the daily mail writes that one of david
cameron's top officials was still
a civil servant when he worked for
controversial firm greenfield capital
that story also makes the front of the
guardian saying downing street
and cabinet office sources are deeply
concerned at the revelation
while the metro takes the angle that
chancellor rishi sunak is
running scared over his role in the
scandal its headline it looks a bit
fishy
rishi so rachel johnson dan hodges are
here plenty to talk about but let's
start with the covert angles of which
there are
many today um dan to the ft first of all
then
uh the johnston and johnson vaccine
halted or halting its role out after
what's happening in america
this once again is an abundance of
caution isn't it over these
rare cases of blood clots
yes and in in my view it's excessive
caution i mean i
i genuinely don't understand this if
this was in in relation to a product
that if you like was being enrolled in
in in say a
a peacetime environment i could
understand this but
but this is a product which is being
rolled out
with a degree of urgency specifically to
deal with a
global health crisis i mean you just
reported on the figures there i think
it's
six cases in relation to the the
millions of
vaccinations that have been distributed
this is going to
significantly impact on the u.s
vaccination
effort where there are already issues in
relation to vaccine take up it will have
a knock-on effect
globally and as ever it will it will
further undermine globally um
confidence in in the vaccine process in
general
and i simply do not see
how the marginal that the microscopic
health benefits that will will accrue
from this pause can be balanced against
the the inevitable deaths
that will arise as a result of the
effective withdrawal of the vaccine it
just
doesn't make any sense to me and rachel
i suppose this was inevitable in some
respects it's a similar
science behind it to the astrazeneca jab
we've seen
uh the response uh to that in the
european union and in fact in many other
parts of the world like australia for
example
um do you think do you agree with dan
that this is
too far i mean the risk of getting a
blood clot as everybody has pointed out
is so much higher if you get coronavirus
itself
totally agree with what dan said it's
also going to
very much impair the rollout of the
vaccine
across europe they were proposing this
is i think which one is it they're going
to do in europe but
a quarter of a 200 million vaccines
uh they were going to do in the next
this next
calendar quarter we're going to be of
the vaccine that has just
had its rollout suspended which means
that
the road light in europe is absolutely
disrupted
at a time when if you compare the risk
of thrombosis
from women who've taken the pill for
many years
it you're one in a million are going to
die from a
a rare blood clot perhaps triggered by
a corona virus vaccination whereas
one in a thousand women will suffer a
thrombosis as a result of taking the
pill
where's the attention on that i cannot i
just cannot understand
uh dan put it very well you know the
dangers of covid
and stopping the vaccination row light
are so much greater
than the dangers of an advantagingly
rare blood clot
so again you know i'm at a loss to
understand the decisions taken
yes indeed um yes johnson johnson said
to supply 55 million
of the 360 million doses that he is
expecting
in the second quarter according to the
ft um
the whole point is of course the 55
million shots enough to immunize
just over a quarter of the 207 million
people that the block hopes to vaccinate
between april and june
because it's a single shot vaccine which
is why everybody was looking forward to
this one certainly
um but dan just before we move on to
other coveted matters
the women involved and they are mainly
women affected by this blood clotting
issue
in the states where 18 to 48 should the
government here
revise um its age by which people
do not get the astrazeneca jab as a
first choice vaccine
to a little older do you think obviously
it's those under 30 that they've decided
not in my view i mean i obviously have
to stress i'm
not not by any sense uh an expert in
this i'm not really
in a position to give it giving that
sort of level of detail advice but just
looking at the figures we have to
remember i mean you've cited six cases
there
the the sample base is so
tiny is so infinite infinitively tiny
i don't see how it can be statistically
significant
to the extent that you can start
amending age brackets
purely on such a such a small a small
sample set
i i just as i said i i literally don't
understand
where the risk assessment is here and
where the cost benefit
analysis is anyway without sort of
re-jigging the the
the age profile that the government's
already outlined
is it could it be anything to do with
insurance people suing
uh you know when you have a vaccine do
you have to sign a disclaimer i don't
think
you do i mean could this be you know
people governments being terrified of
being sued by those who've died
or what is still an elective vaccine i
mean
i don't know i i'm only conjecturing yes
well indeed and we know america is
litigious don't we so it's uh
it's certainly a good point um rachel
let's go to the daily telegraph shall we
which is
new office for national statistics
figures that show that 23 percent
of chronovirus deaths registered are now
thought to be with those who have died
with the virus
rather than from an infection i had
earlier heard that it was 90 percent
who died from coronavirus and not with
it
so this is a slight change um but a
quarter of virus deaths not caused by
the
by covid the delhi telegraph seem to
suggest this is another reason why the
road map should be speeded up yes
i mean it has to be pointed out that the
daily telegraph
along with the daily mail and the mail
on sunday and probably the sun are the
freedom fighting newspapers that are
banging the drum for a faster um
unlocking of the economy so this very
much
plays to that agenda um
it is interesting that suddenly we we
happen to know that 23
of those who died it was with covid
rather than
of covid it rather suggests
it's because they went into hospital for
something and we know that one in four
or five cases
of covid were picked up nosocomially i.e
in a hospital
or care setting so that makes sense
but it is interesting i mean if if they
perhaps want to revise down the numbers
of death
from covid that would also be
interesting we might get a very
different total
after we've got 127 000 people have died
of
of covid if you divide that if uh
by a quarter you get a much much less
figure and of course
um our performance as we call it um
throughout the crisis will begin to look
much better or flat
this ons revision will very much flatter
our performance
yes indeed but this comes does it not um
dan as the prime minister himself said
well effectively saying to people come
on look the figures are so low now
because of lockdown
not the vaccination program and as we
release the lockdown we're inevitably
going to see those figures rising
is this in response do you think to the
the pubs opening and some of the scenes
we've already seen outside
pubs and in in streets across the uk
partially i mean i i i just before i get
to that i'll just
if i could just correct uh rachel on on
one point i mean i can only speak
for the paper i write for but the mail
on sunday isn't actually pushing for a
great acceleration of
oh isn't
the daily mail is yeah but you also said
the mail on sunday rachel so
yeah i thought it was too i thought that
has been on that side of it
they've been on the anyway carry on
but to come on to the come on to the
broader point
i think that's right and i think this i
think this is problematic actually and i
think boris's statement
today in which he suddenly announced or
certainly was it
was interpreted as announcing that that
the success
of uh of the government strategy is
based primarily on the lockdown and not
on the vaccinations
was i think a mixed message and a
dangerous one for all the reasons that
we were we were just
outlining and i do think there's a
sort of an element where the government
on the one hand
tries to give with one hand by saying we
are now reopening you you can go out and
you can go to
shops you can go and drink in pub
gardens
then sees the images we saw last night
particularly in in central london
panics and then tries to get us all not
to do that and it can't frankly have it
both ways
i think the key thing now for the
government is it has to stick to a very
clear simple messaging which is that the
government strategy is working
the vaccination strategy is working if
we listen to the advice
then we are very very near the end of
this national
this national nightmare but this attempt
to try and
manipulate public behavior by this mixed
messaging
i think is uh is frankly
counterproductive
well it's very counterproductive because
it lends credence to those who say
i'm not going to have the vaccine one it
might give me a rare blood clot
and two it hasn't caused the death the
the precipitous falls
in the rates of infection of debt and
death that we should be
rejoicing and triumphing in i mean
i mean i don't have access to the data
that my my brother does but
how how can he possibly know um
whether they fall in deaths to what 28
today within 20 within 28 days of
being tested how can he know whether
it's to do
with the lockdown or the vaccination
roll out
dan i mean what i can't understand
just quickly
like that well as i said i mean i i
think it's less about the facts and more
about how he's trying to
manipulate us in a particular day
yeah he has a lot down sort of eases
down but
when the message does need to be said
you're allowed to the pub but but be
sensible doesn't it that's
you know we need to we do need to know
that uh the yorkshire post as well just
picking up that
before we take a break just quite
quickly the pm warns of a rise in deaths
as the
country unlocks uh as you can see there
restraint is earned
that's the message yes coming up plenty
more are still to come it's looking
fishy for richie according to the metro
find out why after the break thank you
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now i'd like to
say the broadcasting journalist rachel
johnson
i think she's forgotten it's a half
half-hour show anyway
uh commentator for the mail on sunday
dan hodges thankfully he's still in his
seat
i'm glad to see you um so take it away
anyway for the complicated story which
is green sill
cameron the investigation into it and
now the civil servant uh take it away
the ft to start with
well yeah i mean this one we were just
talking about that off air i mean this
one keeps running
but i'm not entirely sure where it's
running
i mean the the new revelations today are
focusing on a i mean it is quite a
bizarre story actually about a a senior
civil servant who apparently
was employed on the board of a private
sector company whilst
simultaneously still being employed as a
as a civil servant which is bizarre in
my view and
there are certainly questions to be
answered there but in terms of the
broader politics i'm not entirely sure
where this goes and i think the primary
reason
is so much of this if not ancient news
is is news and are
based around events that happened
primarily under david cameron's
administration
administration certainly very early in
david cameron's
administration and
the main allegations are basically
focusing towards cameron himself uh
interesting though they are
i'm not entirely sure about the longer
or broader term political impact
for uh for boris and his government
there's been a bit of obviously
rishi sunak's you know been dragged into
this to an extent
but we have to remember that what david
cameron cameron was lobbying for
within the treasury these these cove
these coveted relief funds were not
subsequently awarded to him so rishi
sunak is it
is insulated there and as i said i'm not
entirely sure obviously the headline
there says it looks ambitious